the berlin wall stood here in front of
the brandenburg gate now in the same
spot people are celebrating German
reunification and it's not just
Berliners here Paul Evans and his
colleagues have traveled from Britain
they were here 25 years ago to as
soldiers in the British Army this is a
very memorable time for us we were here
as soldiers so the whole thing happened
overnight and it's been with us ever
since so we had to be here for the 25th
anniversary people who were here the day
the Wall fell showed off their keepsakes
and Auggie Nagy this is a real piece of
the Berlin Wall from this spot here I
chipped it off it's a shame I didn't
take a larger piece with me that's a few
it's from the eastern side of the wall
what kinda I chipped it off right here
tapesh long thousands of balloons have
been set up around the city they were
placed along the route where the wall
previously formed the border between
East and West Berlin llaman scott warren
spahn time spontaneously decided to come
here from our home in Kemnitz to enjoy
this wonderful day together with all the
people who experienced it all 25 years
ago it touched us deeply back then and
we decided it's no different today gosh
thank our testers are so donít
understand us all seven thousand
balloons will be released together to
symbolize the removal of the Berlin Wall